with the Google pay API for Android you
can facilitate payment transactions for
your users making the checkout
experience in your application more
convenient join other businesses like
yours who are using Google pay today to
drive user growth increase conversions
and reduce data exposure and
transactional wonder abilities here is
how you can integrate Google pay on your
Android application in four simple steps
configure your project determine
readiness to pay show the Google pay
button create a payment data request
object first add the Google pay library
to the list of dependencies in your
application module make sure to review
our documentation to check the latest
version available you also need to
enable the Google pay API in your
manifest you can do that by adding the
following tag inside of your application
note as soon as you are ready open the
activity where you plan to show the
Google pay button and obtain a new
instance of the payments client inside
of your oncreate method
note that the get payments client method
takes a wallet options parameter use the
definitions in this class to specify the
environment in which you want to operate
test or production for the test
environment you don't need to register
with Google you can play with the API
yourself and integrate into your
application in this case you can use
real payment information however
whenever a selection is made we return
you a non-chargeable token remember your
real card details are never used when in
environment test but you must add at
least one chargeable card to your Google
account before you proceed once you
complete the integration and you are
ready to handle real payments come and
register with us through our
self-service portal and then flip the
environment to production
you can apply for production access and
G Co slash pay slash sign - up now that
you have your payments client
constructed the first API you need to
call is is ready to pay with is ready to
pay you can determine whether the user
has a valid payment method on file and
is capable of completing a transaction
on a supported device this request takes
parameters that specify the API version
targeted in your call as well as the
payment methods allowed for this
transaction at Google we focus on
optimizing for conversions so if is
ready to pay returns false we highly
recommend that you do not show the
Google pay button now that you know that
the user is ready to make a payment
using Google pay you can make the button
visible to the user we recommend that
you use the graphic shared in the
developer documentation to ensure the
Google pay branding is used correctly
per our latest guidelines in this bundle
you will find drawable and layout
resources that adapt to different screen
sizes and resolutions
as well as translations into multiple
languages for the text in the button
once the user taps on the button you
call the load payment data request to
open up the payment sheet you can
construct the payment data request
object which is a set of payments
configurations used for this particular
transaction you can request additional
information like a shipping address and
email address in addition to the payment
credentials we recommend that you
collect as little information as
necessary to prevent users from typing
additional information which might not
be stored in their accounts one more
point to call out in this object is the
payment request tokenization parameters
Google encrypts information about a
user's selected card for secure
processing by a merchants gateway or
directly on a merchant secured servers
be sure to check your processors
integration guidelines to find out what
they need to finalize the payment
now that you've constructed the request
object you can pass it to load payment
data an asynchronous task which opens
the payments sheet once the user makes a
selection we return to you a payment
data object as an activity result which
consists of metadata about the users
selection it also includes the payment
token which you can use to complete the
transaction now you can send the final
production-ready
application to Google for a final test
Google tests the app with real cards and
informs you if everything is correct the
app is then cleared to launch you can
find additional information in our
developer documentation on G dot KO /
Pei / API don't miss any future videos
about Google pay and Android and
subscribe to the Android developers
Channel if you are watching on a mobile
tap the little Bell to receive new
upload notifications see you soon
you